merci pour cette question essentielle
qu'est ce qui s'est passé il ya
plusieurs mois il s'est passé que des
ennemis nous ont déclaré la guerre
ses ennemis il faut les nommer il faut
les désigner pour ce qu'ils sont
ce sont des islamistes armés de haine et
de folie qui veulent détruire par la
terreur
la plus barbare ne société démocratique
et face à cela nous n'avons pas à nous
excuser d'être ce que nous sommes nous
sommes la france
nous sommes forts de ce que nous sommes
et nous avons tout simplement le devoir
de protéger les français et c'est une
même exigence qui nous traversent tous
que l'on soit aujourd'hui au parlement
où que l'on soit dans les collectivités
locales que l'on soit engagé dans la vie
publique nationale où que l'on soit un
acteur du monde de l'entreprise ou du
monde associatif
on a ce même devoir et moi je suis fier
je dois le dire d'appartenir à ce
mouvement des républicains qui sous la
présidence de nicolas sarkozy fait
toujours le choix de la france on a eu
c'est vrai ce débat à l'assemblée
nationale pendant des semaines sans
doute duré trop longtemps
mais notre responsabilité ça a été de
voter en fonction de nos convictions
ce qui doit l'emporter c'est la sécurité
des français
c'est la protection de la france et des
français
tous ceux qui tuent des français parce
qu'ils sont français ne mérite pas de
l'être nous avons eu raison je le dis de
voter nettement à l'assemblée nationale
en faveur de cette évolution les
terroristes qui tuent des français ne
mérite pas de rester français nous
devons tout faire pour les éradiquer